ce soir j'ai voulu faire débattre de
féministes convaincus sincère et
pourtant de féministe très opposés elles
veulent l'égalité femme homme mais les
moyens pour y parvenir d'y faire
totalement bonsoir Sarah et riz vous
êtes secrétaire d'État à la Jeunesse
dans le gouvernement des Elisabeth borne
pardon Daniel au Bonobo bonsoir vous
êtes la France insoumise de Paris avant
de commencer le débat je voudrais vous
montrer ce numéro de téléphone puisque
nous sommes la Journée mondiale de
l'élimination des violences faites aux
femmes si vous êtes victime ou témoin de
violence le 39 19 et en cas d'urgence
d'urgence appelé le 17 ou envoyer un SMS
au 114 hier on a donc vu deux visages
très différents de l'Assemblée nationale
d'abord lors de la proposition de votre
partie Daniel obono les insoumis pour
inscrire l'IVG dans la Constitution
proposition amendée proposition discuter
puis très largement adopté par
l'Assemblée nationale y compris avec les
voix de la majorité et l'appui de votre
gouvernement Sarah el heri au point au
point que le garde des sceaux et la
présidente du groupe LFI faisait assaut
de politesse après le vote c'est ce sont
des images réalisées sans trucage je
vous le promets
le travail de madame la Présidente pano
aussi les groupes
[Applaudissements]
socialistes
écologiste
communiste collègue je suis très très
émue à la fois de ce vote et de se
signaler historique
que l'Assemblée nationale sonore a
envoyé à toutes les femmes de notre pays
[Applaudissements]
je dois sourire toutes les deux en
gardant ses images vous êtes toutes les
deux très satisfaites de cette issue
madame la ministre oui moi je suis très
satisfaite parce que quand on parle du
droit des femmes il y a pas à politiser
mais il faut être au rendez-vous et ce
texte qui a été proposé par la France
insoumise dans sa niche parlementaire
était au rendez-vous de l'Histoire
aujourd'hui le droit à l'IVG le droit de
de bénéficier de respecter de protéger
son propre corps et mis en danger
partout autour de nous chez nos voisins
européens parfois aux États-Unis partout
dans le monde et ce combat est un combat
qu'il faut mener aujourd'hui inscrire le
droit à l'IVG dans notre Constitution
permettra dans le graver un peu plus
dans le marbre et il est nécessaire
aujourd'hui de poursuivre le parcours de
ce texte il aura le soutien évidemment
de la majorité Daniel obeno avant de
parler de la suite du parcours
satisfaite de l'issue du vote d'hier
mais heureuse d'abord que d'avoir pu
participer à ce moment en tant que
parlementaire parce que je pense que
c'est assez rare à plusieurs égards en
tant que citoyenne en tant que féministe
bien sûr et c'est pas c'est réalisé
c'est un trucage encore une fois et
surtout je crois que c'était vraiment
sincère les remerciements qui ont été
adressés aux uns et aux autres par les
uns et les unes et les autres je pense
ça a été dit donc par le ministre de la
Justice vis-à-vis de Mathilde pano qui
était la rapporteur du texte mais moi je
pense notamment à notre collègue Erwan
Balanant membre de la commission des
lois qui a permis
effectivement que nous ayons une version
commune hier soir oui oui et je pense
que ça mérite d'être souligné et je
pense également à Aurore berger
présidente du groupe Renaissance qui
avait également un texte de loi qui a
porté et qui est venu à l'Assemblée pour
participer au vote et pour annoncer que
ce serait le vote le texte voté hier
serait le seul et unique qui serait
porté auprès du Sénat c'était un geste
très fort elle a fait un témoignage
extrêmement poignant et voilà et donc je
crois que c'est des moments uniques à la
fois en tant que parlementaire on en a
pas vécu beaucoup en 5 ans et je crois
que ce moment est ce texte et ce sujet
nécessitait de prendre cette hauteur de
se rendre compte des enjeux ça a été dit
ce sont des droits fondamentaux c'est un
droit fondamental le droit de disposer
de son corps qui est remis en cause
partout dans le monde et je crois comme
l'a dit Mathilde panneau que ce que nous
avons fait à l'Assemblée nationale par à
la France aux militants et militantes
qui ont porté pendant des années ces
questions mais au-delà même de nos
frontières je crois que c'est aussi un
signe d'espoir aux femmes en Pologne en
gris aux États-Unis qui voit ce droit
reculer donc c'était c'était important
je crois de prendre toute la mesure et
je crois que ça nous oblige aussi à
faire en sorte que effectivement ça
justement de manière on va en parler au
Sénat et que ce soit effectivement gravé
dans la Constitution
je ne savais pas ce qu'elles allaient
dire mais enfin rarement d'uneanimité
entre une ministre et une opposante sur
ce plateau vous l'avez dit maintenant
que le texte aille au Sénat et bien ça
semble être la volonté du Président de
la République il y a eu un vote après il
y a un chemin et donc il faut respecter
ce chemin parlementaire moi ma position
elle a toujours été claire si j'ai fait
le choix
de juillet 2017 de faire entrer au
Panthéon Simone Veil c'est parce que
ma conception des choses et on
attachement profond à la défense d'un
droit qui celui des femmes
librement disposées de leur corps je le
considère comme essentiel à notre
République
alors c'est de la technique
parlementaire mais il faut maintenant
que le texte soit voté dans les mêmes
termes par les sénateurs ce qui n'est
pas acquis mais ce qui n'est pas
impossible mais
après il faudra un référendum un
référendum c'est long c'est compliqué à
organiser c'est cher il y a un moyen de
l'éviter c'est que votre gouvernement ça
va et les rit sans part de ce texte et
en face un projet de loi est-ce que vous
le souhaitez être personnel je le
souhaite et vous avez entendu président
de la République il souhaite que le
combat de l'égalité et aujourd'hui
protégé l'IVG en fait partie protéger
libérée c'est l'inscrire dans la
Constitution alors j'ai la conviction
qu'on trouvera les voix et moyens pour y
arriver y arriver avec le même consensus
la même force pour l'inscrire dans la
Constitution et rendre ce droit avec le
protéger ce droit avec un rempart j'ai
entendu le président de la technique
parlementaire c'est compliqué si c'est
un ce qu'on appelle un projet de loi
donc
d'initiative une proposition de loi
pardon donc d'initiative parlementaire
ça doit être obligatoire obligatoirement
valider par un référendum si c'est un
projet de loi venu du gouvernement ça
peut être le Congrès j'ai pas rêvé vous
souhaitez que ça soit un projet de loi
proposé par le gouvernement la réponse
elle arrivera quel que soit la forme moi
ce que je souhaite la forme moi ce que
je souhaite c'est que demain le Sénat le
vote parce que ce sera un signal qui
renforce ensuite la manière la plus
rapide soit c'est un projet de loi soit
c'est un référendum tu es la conviction
que dans les deux cas
aujourd'hui avec ce qui s'est passé hier
à l'Assemblée nationale le droit à l'IVG
le droit de disposer de son corps
absolument essentiel et les mental sera
inscrit dans notre Constitution et c'est
ça qui me touche aujourd'hui je crois
que c'est l'essentiel est-ce que vous
prenez acte de la de la volonté
c'est-à-dire que les débats de la
volonté des membres de la majorité
d'avancer sur ce débat oui et c'est
heureux et nous espérons et nous
attendons de voir le dérouler en
espérant que ce soit le plus rapide
possible je pense que il faut que le
Sénat aussi puisse prononcer parce que
ça aura d'autant plus de de poids et
c'est aussi un signal que le Sénat
puisse adopter ce texte effectivement le
projet de loi permettrait que ça aille
plus vite mais je tiens à rappeler quand
même également que c'est une proposition
qui est majoritaire dans la société en
vérité 75 60 plus de 75 % des des
Français et les Français sont favorables
à cela donc en fait toutes les
conditions sont réunies aujourd'hui
réunies pour que ce soit fait et très
rapidement
c'est donc aujourd'hui la Journée
mondiale de l'élimination des violences
faites aux femmes sur cette cause
peut-il y avoir la même entente entre
vos deux camps que pour l'IVG Daniel au
Bono
ça dépend sur quoi exactement et puis
après on est dans un débat politique et
la question c'est aussi quels sont les
objectifs sur quoi on peut ou pas se
mettre d'accord et quels sont les moyens
et les méthodes pour y arriver donc
ensuite en fonction des sensibilités
politiques des histoires et des
programmes que l'on défend après tout
nous avons des programmes différents
nous nous sommes dans l'opposition nous
souhaitons gouverner d'une manière
différente que de fait le gouvernement
actuel et donc nous aurons des
propositions différentes des leurres ou
en tout cas en terme de méthode de
moyens et de stratégie on va voir les
chiffres des féminicides cette année
voilà en 2022 225 000 femmes victimes de
violence 121 féminicides ça veut dire en
tous les deux jours en gros ce sont des
chiffres il y en a déjà plus cette année
que il en a déjà plus là pour les 10
premiers mois de l'année que pour toute
l'année dernière est-ce que le
gouvernement en fait assez pour lutter
contre les féministes ça va être il y
aura un féminicite tant qu'il y aura une
femme sous qui est sous les coups de son
conjoint ce ne sera pas assez et là je
suis absolument clair le combat qui est
le nôtre pour l'égalité entre les femmes
et les hommes pour aussi
finir en finir avec ses violences et
bien c'est un combat comporte depuis
2017 parce que le Président de la
République en a fait une cause nationale
et celle la réitérée après il faut des
moyens des mesures les associations
demandent un milliard pour l'instant ne
les ont pas 2 milliards 2,4 milliards de
budget l'année prochaine 1,1 cas 1,4
milliards cette année c'est le
renforcement des forces de l'ordre des
forces de police et leur formation
gendarmerie et police le doublement
aujourd'hui des moyens pour accueillir
plus de femmes et les mettre à l'abri
les protéger toujours allez à chercher
plus de bracelets
éloignement des téléphones d'appel
d'urgence c'est quatre lois qui ont été
votées depuis 2017 ça c'est ce que nous
avons fait il n'y a pas que ça parce
qu'en lutter contre ces violences c'est
trois actes trois temps d'abord prévenir
parler l'éducation toujours ensuite
protéger protéger les femmes croire en
leurs paroles les mettre à l'abri
protéger leurs enfants enlevez les armes
de leur conjoint parce qu'elle meurent
parfois malheureusement parce que les
leurs conjoints ont des armes sur eux
éloignés ces conjoints au maximum avoir
une justice plus rapide en lui donnant
les moyens ça c'est la partie protection
et ensuite il y a les sanctions les
sanctions contre les hommes
majoritairement qui sont violents
éloignés aussi et protéger les enfants
de ces âmes violents ce sont des lois ce
sont des transformations en profondeur
ce sont des moyens financiers mais face
à ça nous avons pour le coup pas les
mêmes pas les mêmes réponses et les
mêmes soutiens parce que nos projets
politiques ne sont pas les mêmes je sens
que c'est justement la fin du consensus
auquel on a assisté depuis le début de
cette émission vous vous trompez que le
gouvernement c'est assez ou pas et
c'était pas simplement moi ou nous la
France insoumise le 19 novembre dernier
il y avait plus de 100.000 personnes
dans la rue et parmi les raisons pour
lesquelles il y avait autant de personne
dans la rue elle appelle du collectif
nous toutes pour lutter contre les
violences faites aux femmes c'était
notamment parce que il y a un constat
largement partagé des insuffisances et
du bilan plus que mitigé du gouvernement
au cours des cinq dernières années
d'autant plus flagrant que effectivement
ça a été porté comme une grande cause en
2017 et que c'est à nouveau présenté
comme cela mais le compte n'y est pas
tout simplement pas et les mots et les
vœux pieux ne suffisent pas aujourd'hui
pour répondre à ce que demande le les
collectifs de victimes les associations
j'aurais juste rappeler quand même que
on a commencé ce mandat avec une mesure
qui a littéralement empêché que nous
ayons ce débat à l'Assemblée
c'est-à-dire le 49-3 le 49-3 sur le
budget ça a signifié que nous n'avons
pas pu avoir ce déballage sur les moyens
et nous n'avons pas pu y compris
notamment faire le point sur le fameux
milliard que demande toujours les
associations d'ailleurs aujourd'hui il y
a une révocation qui est d'aller jusqu'à
2 milliards c'est à dire à une portion
du PIB qui soit à la hauteur parce que
les besoins sont elles nous n'avons pas
pu avoir ce débat et ça c'est un des
problèmes majeurs que nous avons avec ce
gouvernement c'est-à-dire le fait
d'avoir une vision budgétaire qui fait
que malgré les bonnes intentions c'est
pas un procédé d'intention que nous
faisons c'est que la logique politique
économique empêche de dégager les moyens
financiers pour mettre absolument pas de
même à 2 milliards les 1 à 2 milliards
qui sont nécessaires pour l'hébergement
juste ratés vous avez des milliards au
budget vous avez donné le chiffre des
plus de 200000 femmes qui sont victimes
de vie intraconjugal aujourd'hui combien
il y a de place d'hébergement
disponibles vous parliez de la question
de exactement et l'éloignement c'est
ridicule c'est à peu près 17000 à peu
près je crois place des berges
entre ce qui est mis pas suffisant et
les 2017 un deuxième exemple 19 il a
fallu une bataille pendant le même jour
24 il a fallu une bataille je vous
recommande toujours sur cette vous
reconnaissez qu'il a failli une bataille
pour que
ce 39 19 il a été mis en danger
justement et les moyens donnés aux
associations qui utilisaient et gérer ce
39 19 ont failli être enterré sans qu'il
y ait aujourd'hui est-ce que je voudrais
reprendre confiance
vous avez chacune qui parlait de vos
moyens je voudrais du roman 24 sur des
travaux pratiques puisque vous avez loué
le consensus qui régnait hier pour l'IVG
Aurélien Pradier donc le député
républicain candidat à la présidence de
son parti a déposé une proposition de
loi qui propose d'instaurer un tribunal
des violences intra familiales sur le
modèle par exemple du tribunal des
enfants estimant que ça serait un moyen
plus efficace de lutter contre les
violences familiales est-ce que vous
pourriez toutes les deux ou qui n’êtes
ni l'un ni l'autre républicaine est-ce
que vous pourriez toutes les deux
soutenir cette proposition Daniel au
Bonin alors nous sommes toutes les deux
je crois républicaines nous ne sommes
pas nous ne faisons pas membre du vous
avez raison et il se trouve que notre
eau pas nous avons participé aux
discussions en commission le texte a
changé et c'était heureux qu'il change
parce que la proposition ces derniers
que ce soit des pôles spécialisés pas
justement des juridictions en tant
qu'elles parce que nous nous sommes
assez critiques des jeux de l'extension
à l'infini des juridictions spécialisés
il faut donner des moyens à toute la
justice et spécialiser les magistrats et
notamment les formations mais tout ça
normal sous sa forme actuelle vous va
vous montrer ensemble ce serait une
avancée on pense que c'est positif donc
vous voudrez cette proposition ça fait
partie des propositions nous avions dans
notre programme et nous sommes heureuses
de voir qu'Aurélien Pradet et les
républicains nous rejoignent sur ce
point donc la vôtre oui c'est elle
arrive en débat et s'il n'y a pas de
risque le gouvernement va la soutenir et
vous trouvez ça ça tombe bien parce
qu'il se trouve que la première ministre
Amanda tes deux parlementaires pour
travailler sur quelle est la réponse
spécialisée la plus juste et la plus la
plus finie ce n'était pas moi je n'étais
pas en commission puisque aujourd'hui je
suis au gouvernement donc je ne maîtrise
pas ce texte en profondeur et il se
trouve il se trouve que pour répondre
aux violences faites aux femmes il faut
voter des textes et des textes de loi
c'est pour ça qu'il faut voter les
moyens à la police c'est pour ça qu'il
faut voter aujourd'hui les moyens pour
la justice c'est pour ça qu'il faut
voter en réalité les moyens aussi dans
lequel les fesses et ces outils c'est la
loi de sécurité sociale ces outils c'est
ce qui nous permet en réalité d'arriver
4 milliards mais je tiens parce que je
ne veux pas qu'on laisse imaginer qu'on
manque de moyens financiers aujourd'hui
tant qu'il y aura une femme qui prend
des coups qui subit des coups ou qui
considéré que vous avez augmenté les
moyens financiers et c'est pour autant
et que pour autant il en manque et c'est
et aujourd'hui ce qui est vrai ce qui
est vrai c'est que tant que ce tant
qu'on subit tant qu'il y a des femmes
qui subissent des violences il ne faudra
jamais les Aigner sur les moyens hier je
vais vous reposer la question hier le
gouvernement a voté une proposition de
loi venant de la France insoumise est-ce
que vous pourriez voter Daniel Baudot a
dit clairement oui on votera la
proposition de loi Pradier est-ce que la
majorité la votera c'est simple un
tribunal des violences intra familiales
c'est assez simple
spécialisés ce qui n'est pas exactement
le même exercice c'est un tribunal mais
le texte a évolué en commission
est-ce que vous serez d'accord
spécialisation le gouvernement n'a pas
n'a pas soutenu ce test nous sommes pour
une spécialisation dans les juridictions
pour avoir plus de personnes
spécialisées pour accueillir la parole
et accompagner ces procédures là
aujourd'hui la première ministre Amanda
tes deux parlementaires une autre député
et une sénatrice donc les compléments
par le collègue pradé donc pas besoin de
refaire une commission et de perdre du
temps ce n'est pas des experts
extérieurs ce sont deux parlementaires
c'est votre collègue c'est votre
collègue de mémoire Chandler à
l'Assemblée et une sénatrice également
et donc c'est finalement aller chercher
l'unité aussi sur ce sujet là